hey youtubers it's Charlie this week for
my Game of Thrones bonus video I wanted
to talk about all my favourite
characters that the TV show has
completely cut out so just careful for
spoilers for everything that the books
have covered so far now there are way
more than 10 characters that the show
has cut out these are just going to be
my favorites and keep in mind that we
haven't got winds of winter or dream of
spring yet and these are only from the
main novels they don't include anybody
from the short stories and there is a
new round of the giveaway but I'm gonna
talk about that at the end of this so
let's start with number 10
missing-in-action patch face attached to
Stannis's storyline in the books he's
kind of like a court jester his
backstory is fascinating though
Stannis's father
Steffon Baratheon found him when he was
travelling overseas thought that he
would make a great entertainer for his
three sons Robert Stannis and Renly and
on the way back to storms end the ship
crashed
everyone drown including Stannis's
parents patch face was the only survivor
he washed up on shore being completely
crazy talked and had gone half mad in
Stannis decided to keep him around once
Shireen took a liking to him as she
didn't have any childhood friends one of
the really big reasons people were upset
that he wasn't included on the show is
just because they feel like he speaks in
prophesies he speaks in really strange
riddles but seemingly predicts big WTF
events like the red wedding that's just
one example
he just one of those characters that has
a lot of crazy theories attached to them
number nine Victarion Greyjoy currently
missing in action especially considering
season six is bringing on his brother
Euron Greyjoy but for season six a lot
of people had given up hope on all of
the Greyjoy uncles although technically
the damp hair had been featured before
just not in a really big way he's this
character here in season two giving the
Drowned God's blessing to Theon before
he tries to sack Winterfell and then you
will also kind of see him in the season
6 trailer doing the same thing with
Joran Greyjoy what is dead may never die
one of the reasons I think they might
not include Victarion is because they're
gonna do a smaller version of the
Kingsmoot from the books and without
getting into super spoilers that's kind
of like an internal conflict amongst the
Ironborn it also feels like they're
gonna give a lot of Victorian storyline
in the books to you're on the show has a
history of doing this where characters
that are cut out have a really important
store line that they want to do but they
don't want to add cast so they have some
other character do an important thing
which I'll talk about now actually heed
Rick's
storm who was sacrificed by the TV show
in favor of Gendry who I know a lot of
people are still wondering about still
rowing his way back to flea bottom in
the books
Eirik storm just gets the Gendry leeches
storyline he's another one of Roberts
bastards so because they already had one
of Roberts bastards on the show they're
just like okay we'll just have
Melisandre leech him up instead number
seven Fargo Haute in the books he was
the leader of the brave companions the
TV show replaced him with the lock
character they didn't really explain why
they changed the name but I think it has
something to do with completely changing
that character storyline the biggest
event that he's associated with in the
books is cutting off one of Jaime's
hands but the TV show sent him to the
wall later got him caught up with this
Jon Snow storyline so it got
dramatically changed so maybe because
they knew they were gonna do
dramatically different things with the
Vargo hOAT character they just decided
to outright change his name number six
strong bail was-- a lot of people
disappointed that he's not on the show
because he's kind of a funny character
also a big badass literally a big badass
he's a huge person
imagine a cuddlier version of the
mountain only he's associated with
Daenerys his storyline in the books he's
owned by Illyrio and he's sent to track
down Daenerys but he gets caught up in
Daenerys his storyline before he was
owned by Illyrio he came up through the
fighting pits in Mereen - so
thematically he also informs part of
Daenerys his decision to try and end
slavery just because of the really awful
life that he led growing up even though
he's actually really proud of his
accomplishments one of the reasons I
think the show cut him out is just
because it wasn't spending as much time
with the Daenerys character and she
already had a couple big characters
around her like Daario Jorah Barristan
Selmy in the TV show just wanted to
focus more on them so blame them for no
strong bail wasps number five
Arianne Martell pretty big character in
the grand scheme of things so it was a
big deal when the show cut her out but
just like with strong bail was they had
already picked a couple really big
characters from the door--and storyline
in the books to do and it seems like
their intention wasn't to spend a lot of
time in door just a brief period when
Jaime tried to rescue Marcella and I
know a lot of book readers were really
upset because of all the storylines that
they've changed on the books the Dorne
storyline during season five was one of
the most change just because of the
characters involved in some of the
twists that they try to do from the
books the interesting thing about that
and the showrunners have addressed this
the butterfly effect you know them
changing small things up front so it
as bigger changes later on number four
missing character Quentyn Martell also
sacrificed because of all the season
five changes they made to Doran who gets
tied up in a Big Dance with Dragons
storyline so without giving away
spoilers what it seems like they're
going to do is they will do a Quentin
like storyline only they'll divide it
between trystane and Tyrion in they'll
change one of the big WTF from that if
you know what the big Quentyn Martell
WTF twist is from the books please use
spoiler tags if you're gonna comment
about it because I think we're gonna see
a version of it during season six number
three penny the dwarf this part of
Tyrion storyline during the books I
always felt like her storyline in the
books was meant to add complexity to
Tyrion emotional complexity because
she's this really genteel good character
but she reminds Tyrion of all the things
that he hates about himself namely the
way he looks and he just can't handle
her being so nice to him so he recoils
from it and she was also at the purple
wedding in the scene where he dresses
the dwarves up to reenact the war of the
five kings penny and her brother were
made to dress up and ride around on a
pig and a dog and it seems like the show
really just wanted to focus on Tyrion
and Jorah storyline on their travels so
now with everything going on in season
six Terence mostly going to be paired
with Daenerys as small Council as they
try to keep marine from burning itself
to the ground
number two missing character cold hands
really big character from the books that
people always had a bunch of theories
about a lot of people thought that he
might be Benjen Stark
really his purpose is to help bran get
to the three-eyed Raven and he's already
done that on the show so they probably
just thought that they didn't need that
extra character but he has this really
strange appearance he looks kind of like
a white Walker but he's not fully a
white Walker a lot of people think that
he might be the former night's king he's
just there to usher in a new part of the
story so I'm not expecting to see him in
any future season of the show george RR
martin has already shot down the bench
in theory he's definitely not Benjen but
i do think for all you who are wondering
where benjin is the TV show will answer
that question at some point before the
series finale it might not be the answer
you want but I do think that the show is
gonna try and answer all of the
questions that it raises not including
the characters and storylines that it
completely cuts out so if you see
something on the show that has thus far
gone unresolved just expect the show to
answer it before it goes off the air for
good and my number one missing character
Aegon some of you may have guessed this
new challenger for the throne in
Westeros as Dance with Dragons as
ramping up he's building a force to lead
a coup now thus far all the characters
that get involved with his storyline
have already gone on to do other things
they've already skipped past that
storyline in the books so what I think
happened is is the TV show just wanted
to focus more on the internal conflict
of politicking within King's Landing
rather than have to deal with this other
outside challenger so instead of all
this agon chaos that's going to be
happening in the books I think the TV
show is just focusing on the chaos
between Cersei in the faith a battle
that they teased in the season 6 trailer
I choose violence in my bonus number 0
character Lady Stoneheart
now because she's kind of super spoilery
if you haven't read the books I won't
talk too much about her all I'll say is
that they're kind of dividing the WTF
aspects of her storyline and giving them
to other characters like they didn't
want to do Lady Stoneheart because it
would have tipped the Hat for a really
big WTF event that's gonna happen with
another character in thematically she's
the most visceral expression of revenge
for a very certain house and I think
they wanted to give that revenge payoff
to another character from that house so
the spirit of Lady Stoneheart is just
being divided between a couple
characters in the book we can talk more
about that when they actually pay those
moments off on the TV show but let me
know in the comments who's your favorite
character from the books that you are a
hundred percent certain the show is cut
out and we won't see in the next two
seasons because remember there are two
seasons after season six a giveaway time
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner mark Dowling you win a $20 Amazon
gift card just be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I get your contact details that's
just on the about page and there is a
new round of the giveaway that I'm
starting now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video we are now within a couple
weeks of the show premiering I know a
couple people requested like a catch-up
video like everything that's happened on
the show so far I'm probably gonna save
that video till we get a little bit
closer to the show but there are any
specific bonus videos or anything you
guys want me to explain in particular
just let me know in the comments
a lot of the bonus videos that I do
while the episodes are actually
happening will just depend on some of
the storylines that they go with during
season six there are a couple things
that I'm pretty sure they're doing in a
couple things I think they might do so
we'll just wait and see
the other really big news is tonight is
the Walking Dead Season 6 finale they're
doing a big comic book WTF well you guys
wait for me to post that you can
here for my last big game of Thrones
trailer breakdown and you can click here
to learn all about negan from The
Walking Dead thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you